Film Courage: I’m wondering if the two
of you can tell me about how your editor made
sense of all the footage? I know you spent
like 5 or 6 years with him [Artist and Documentary
Subject Chris Burden] and were very close
to Chris and close to the footage as well.
How did your editorreally help shape the
film? Timothy Marrinan: Yeah, it was a really
important process. As you say, we spent
a long time filming with Chris, lots of different
pieces. We went through his archives, so
there’s a lot of raw material there to piece
together into a cohesive story.  We worked
with two editors, Michael Aaglund andAaron
Wickenden, who were fantastic editors. And
it was so useful to have them come in with
a little more distance than we had, because
we had been so close to it for so long. So
to get their sort of fresh eyes on the project
and help us figure out what was important
to go in there and what wasn’t and helpshape
that story, they were fantastic and it was
a really important part ofthe process of
making the film. Film Courage: How much
footage did you have of Chris over the years?
Timothy Marrinan: I suppose it’s hard
to say in terms of specific kind of hours
and things, but the film took shape over a
number of years because Chris’s sculptures
take a long time to come together. He works
on these things for a number of years before
they kind of come together into a finished
piece. So our process was visiting him periodically
at his studio, checking in on what he was
working on, and trying to trace the development
of different pieces he was working on, so
we ended up with a lot of footage with him.
We shot at his studio. We also filmed
installations and openings of various pieces
and then there is a huge amount of archival
material, as well. He opened up his archives
to us.  So we went back in there to not
only find documentation of his performance
works and his earlier works, but we also did
a lot of digging outside of that to find interviews
with Chris from earlier periods in his career
to try to really bring those time periods
to life, as well as other related material.
It’s hard to give a specific number but
there was a lot [of footage] to work with.
Again, working with our editors and working
together to try to make sense of that and
to pick what the important parts were was
a big process. So we thought it went really
well. Film Courage: It was excellent (by
the way) seeing him [Chris Burden interviewed]
with RegisPhilbin and it was interesting
to see both of those worlds contrast. I’m
wondering how [the two of you] viewing Chris
and his work has also shaped how you view
your work? How you view artists in general?
Because he was so different for his time
[has this allowed you] to feel freedom in
your own work? Or were you two just so enthralled
with Chris that you just focused [solely on
him]? Had it changed your view of art in
any way and what you do, [as a result of working
with him]? Richard Dewey: I think getting
a first-hand view of his process was very
important and he was very patient. I think
an idea that came out a lot was that sometimes
with patience and a process, that takes a
long time. Things can come out of that where
you go down a path that’s unexpected, you
make a discovery that’s unexpected and that
happens over the course of years. So I think
my takeaway and influence from Chris’s work
is really just how important the process is
and that patience can really be a virtue in
art. Timothy Marrinan: I would absolutely
agree. That was an interesting thing to
learn about. And I guess one other thing
I found quite inspiring about Chris once we
got to know him and dig into his art was his
commitment to the work. You know, whether
it was his early pieces where he was often
quite literally putting his body on the line
to explore an idea that was interesting to
him. Or his later pieces which I said can
take many yearsand a lot of investmentof
both time and money to sort of bring together.
Often he started those pieces without a
clear idea of exactly where they would finish
or if they would end up in an institution
or bought by a collector or something like
that. He really had a lot of dedication
to his art, a really clear vision of what
he wanted to do (which he stuck to).  And
that was interesting and inspiring, I think.
Film Courage: I have a quote from Chris
and he says “I don’t have to make an object
to have it be art. The performance itself
can be art.” So since Chris reallylived
in public, would you say his whole life was
an act of artistry in some sense? Richard
Dewey: I think it’s possible to make that
argument for the first part of his life but
I think there is a real line for the second
part of his life where that is not the case
and he became a very private person. There
was a real separation between his private
life and his public life and in his life in
the art world. And I think Chris really
valued that and I think the work benefitedfrom
it as well. I don’t think doing the performances
he did and having the blur between his private
and public life was long-term sustainable
for him or anyone. Film Courage: It was
interesting [in the film] to see him on his
[secluded] Topanga Canyon property and at
one point in the film it refers to the fact
that he didn’t want to leave as was alluded
to in the film and he felt safe there. Because
he was so polarizing to those in the art world,
do you think that is why he stayed there [close
to home] because he felt more protected? He
could control what happened to him? Timothy
Marrinan: I think it’s probably fair to
say or I would think that the way he did become
more private in the second half of his career
is probably a reaction to his time doing performances.
Whereas Rich said, there was this real blurred
line between his public life and his private
life. But I think that once he moved up
to Topanga, you know he bought some land up
there, in the late 70’s/early 80’s and
over time built up a studio and a home up
there. It was just a place where he was
really comfortable. And it was kind of his
place to experiment with new ideas. He was
always really interested in what the next
project was. He was focused on what he was
doing next and got so immersed in that and
excited by that. So I think it was a place
where he just felt really comfortable to experiment
with new art works and to pursue the things
that were most interesting to him. It was
a very comfortable and a creatively free place
for him. Film Courage: How would you compare
Chris’s life in the 1970’s to today’s
selfie culture and vloggers where we all (essentially)
in the modern world live in public and desire
to do so? He was doing this all before it
became [everyone’s current way of living
in 2017]. Timothy Marrinan: It’s interesting.
Yes. I think that elements of what he
was doing then are precursor to what you see
now. He did some pieces where he took control
of TV in that he would put his artwork…he
would buy ad space on TV and broadcast his
artworks there. You see one [spot] right
at the start of our film and that was really
exciting to him. You know, the idea that he
was sort of pushing his art into a non-art
context and reaching a new audience with it.
And I suppose in a lot of ways, what he
did then was kind of a precursor to what you
see in the culture more broadly now. Film
Courage: But he was also criticized for
that ad in some sense, wasn’t he? Timothy
Marrinan: Yeah, I think that people to a
certain extent felt slightly…well some people
felt a little bit attacked by it. That they
weren’t expecting to see this artwork and
then all the sudden they are watching TV and
this thing [advertisement] pops in their face.
But I think he enjoyed that element of it
as well and that reaction to it.